ณ
วัด
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนรู้เองอะไรค่ะอันนี้วันอะไรคะ
สกรีนค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันอะไรตัว
เองชัด Skin ไม่เสร็จแล้วเรียนจะได้ฟัง
ผู้หญิงร้องเพลงอยู่นะ
อันนี้วันนี้คุยผู้หญิงโอเคไหมเห็นไหม
เดี๋ยวพี่หากู a  Format  background ปิด
ได้ไหมคะ
โอเค
กูอีกขอขยายผู้หญิงก่อนนะพี่จะได้เห็นผู้
หญิงเยอะๆค่ะ
Love สักครู่นะคะอ้าโอเคผู้หญิงคะวันนี้
วันอะไรคะอันนี้วันตั้งค่าวันศุกร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 ค่ะวันที่ 10
เราเล่าวันที่ผิดหรือเปล่าเนี่ยมันนั่น
น่ะสิ
10  11  12 แล้ววันที่ 10 นะหน้า
4  5
โอเคสมัยเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิ.ย.ค่ะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2556  5  3
ปีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลาง
อ่ะ 4 โมง
57 นาที 4
4  2  57 นาทีครูหญิงกับคุ่ก็ต้องพูดจน
ถึงกี่โมงคะขึ้นถึง
05:20 น
7 นาทีหรอคะ
17:00 น 27 นาทีนะคะค่ะทั้งหมดกี่นาทีคะ
นั่นสิคะ
30 นาทีมะดื่มน้ำอยู่น้ำส้มไหมคะกำลังงง
ดื่มน้ำส้มได้คะผู้หญิงมีน้ำเปล่า
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงวันนี้วันนี้ครูมีอันนี้คุณ
นี้คำถามเหรอคะ
มีคำถามนิดหน่อยโอเคได้ค่ะใช่ครูเอ๋วัด
ก่อนนะคะค่ะคุณจะว่าอะไรคะเอกวัฒน์อาหมาย
ก่อนค่ะอันนี้เป็นต้นไม้นะคะครูหญิงค่ะ
ตอนนี้กูเองวาดแครอท
เหมือนไหม
ไม่ต้องเลือกว่าแครอทด้วยเพราะว่าครูหญิง
ชอบแครอท
แครอทคาเนี่ยแครอทแครอทเป็นอะไรอ่ะหัด
เป็นผักนะคะ
กูอีกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้คือหญิง
ชุดดอกไม้
ดอกไม้มีต้นไม้มีแครอทมีดอกไม้ต้นไม้อัด
จะเป็นต้นไม้หรือเป็นต้นแอปเปิ้ลก็ได้นะ
นะครับอ่ะทั้งหมดตรงนี้เราเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
ผู้หญิง
คลื่นเหรอคะพี่อาร์ทีเก่งมากอื้มนะคะหาก
ผู้หญิงดูต่อไปกูอีกวะกไก่ไก่ว่าอะไรอีก
อะไรคะครึ่งอ่ะฮ้างวูทำไมรู้ผู้หญิงเคย
เห็นครูเอกว่าแล้วหนูช้างอ้วนดีแล้วกูเอง
ช้างน่ารัก
ช้างๆๆว่าอะไรคะ
ลางอ่ะลาคุยวัดอะไรคะ
ปลาหมึก
ใช่ระเบิดทั้ง 6 ค่ะ
ช้างปลาปลาหมึกนี่เป็นอะไรคะผู้หญิง
สัตว์ค่ะ
อะไรนะสัตว์
ขอบคุณค่ะ
เห็นทางวิ่งก็ตอบเนาะจะวัดอะไรอีกไหมคะ
แต่ว่าอันนี้อะไรเอ่ยรู้อ่ะที่สี่เหลี่ยม
ผืนผ้าทีวี
ทีวีครูเอ๋วาดโอเค
นิ
แล้วก็มีมีดอกไม้แจกัน
แจกัน
ค่ะอันนี้
ต.ตะไรคะโต๊ะโต๊ะ
อันนี้อะไรคะ
รสค่ะรสทั้งหมดเรียกว่าอะไรคะสิ่งของสิ่ง
ของนะคะมั่งแล้วก็มีอะ
อะไรคะคุยว่าชายวัดผู้ชาย
หรือผู้หญิง
ว่าอะไรคะ
เด็กเด็กอะไรคะเด็กผู้หญิง
อ่าวาดอะไรคะ
คนแก่อุ้ยเก่งมากคนแก่ๆ
ปั๊มจะ
เราเลยแล้วทั้งหมดตรงนี้ตรงนี้ทั้งหมดเรา
เรียกว่าอะไรคะชนคนนะคะคนนั้นน่ะงั้น
เนี่ยตอนนี้ที่กูเอกไหว้ก็จะมีหนึ่ง
อะไรนะคะทั้งหมดเห้ยพืช
สองสัตว์
3 สิ่งของ 4
คน
คนนะคะก็จะมีพืช
ฝากสิ่งของเราก็คนมี 4 อย่างอ่าใช่สระผู้
หญิงจะไปทำได้อย่างนี้พูดว่าทำไมไงผู้
หญิงอยากรู้
เธอคือคนไทยอุ๊ยผู้หญิงได้ยินเสียงอะไร
ข้างนอกไหมลูกมีรูปขายทุเรียนเหรอเหรอโทษ
นักเรียนกูเองไม่ยอมปิดหมดแล้วแต่เสียง
เข้ามาไม่เป็นไรไม่ได้ยินแล้วค่ะไม่ได้
ยินแล้ว
คือคู๋จะบอกว่ากูอ่ะมาดูที่คนนะคะครูเอก
คอร์ดลบอันนี้ก่อน
คนค่ะๆคนเนี่ยอ่ะโอ๋เอ๋มีรูป
วาดบ่ายต่อทาช่าวัดคนคนก็จะมีผู้ชายใช่
ไหมรถไปทำไมค่ะ
นั่งรักก็ผู้หญิงค่ะนี่
คนไทยเนี่ยเขาจะเปรียบเทียบ
เปรียบเทียบ
คนจะรักผู้หญิงน่ะผู้หญิงกับ
คืออะไรหนอ
ถ้าเปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงกับสิ่งของ
เปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงกับปีกมีสัตว์ด้วยนะมี
ด้วยโอโห้แต่วันนี้กูเองไม่มีรูปสัตว์นะ
คะอ่ะผู้หญิงมีรูปส่วนนะคะถ้ากูอยากจะ
เปรียบเทียบกับอะไรได้ได้เอาสัตว์ก่อนก็
ได้ค่ะคุยว่าได้คู่หญิงใช่แล้วคนไทย
เปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงกับสัตว์อะไรอ่ะผู้
หญิงเหมือนสัตว์อะไรอย่างนี้หรอคะบางที
บอกเหมือนสัตว์อะไร
เดินใช่ไหมผู้หญิงเดินเหมือนสัตว์อะไรเอา
ผู้หญิงเดินเหมือนสัตว์อะไรคะครูเอ๋เขา
บอกว่าผู้หญิงดีๆต้องเดินเดินเดินเหมือน
ช้างช้างเนี่ย
ก็คุยวาดรูปช้างใช่ไหม
อันนี้หูชายนะคะค่ะทำไมอ่ะ
ครูหญิงช้างหน้าตัวใหญ่ไหมตัวใหญ่ค่ะเวลา
เดินอ่ะช้าช้าๆเบาเบาๆหอมผู้หญิงไทยเนี่ย
ต้องเดินช้าๆเดินเอาเบาเดินเบาๆเพราะว่า
บ้านไทย
เป็นแบบนี้
บ้านไผ่เป็นไม้ค่ะ
บ้านบ้านเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนเป็น
ไม้ค่ะเป็นไม้ต้องเดินเบาเบาๆๆถ้าเดินแรง
ๆหรอคะเดินแรงๆเหมือนม้านะนี่นะนี่ก็
คุยว่าไงเนี่ย
ได้คุยว่าได้ค่ะพระเอกเก่งคุณมาอ๋อเหมือน
มั้ยเหมือนหมู
เหมือนหมาแล้วปลาได้อยู่แล้วได้แล้วไม่
ใช่แล้วนะเฮ้อ
โอเค
มีค่ะคุยว่านม้าใช่ไหมอะนี้มาหรือเปล่านะ
ลูกที่ 1 ยกมาเนี่ยโอเคว่าโอเคอ่า
ม้าคะคนไทยบอกว่าผู้หญิงและต้องเดินให้
เหมือนช้างค่ะให้เดินเหมือนม้าขอหมาเดิน
เสียงดังหรอคะใช่มั้ยมาเนี่ยจะ
ขอไม่ดีถ้าเดินเดินนะคะอ่ะ
ไปหาเดินนะมีเสียงกับเสียงดังไม่ดีราคาก็
ผู้หญิงก็ต้องเดินเหมือนช้างไปเดินๆ
แล้วก็บางทีก็บอกว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้น่ารัก
เหมือนกระต่าย
ผู้หญิงนี่กระต่ายไหมเนี่ยฉันรักเนื้อกู
อีกว่าได้กระต่ายอ่ะได้ค่ะครูเทวะกระต่าย
ให้นักเรียนดู
[เพลง]
กระต่ายค่ะ
แล้วจะตายก็ตายชอบกินแครอทไงอ๋อผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเวลาดูรอบๆน่ารักเหมือนกระต่ายไม่
เหมือนกระต่ายเหมือนแมว
เหมือนนกยังไงอ่ะก็เหมือนนก
ครูเอ๋
คะน่ากลัว
ทั้งผู้หญิงน่ากลัวเหมือนอะไรเหมือนเสือ
เห็นไหมนางเอกว่าได้ไหมเสือเห็นค่ะเห็น
ทั้งหมดเลยกูเอ๋อ่า
หน้า
เสือก็กูไม่ต้อง
Code แอร์
เสือค่ะขอ
โทษนักเรียนแอปแซ่บมากนะคะนะมีหายเมื่อ
ไหร่ทำไมคุณไม่เอาขึ้นมาเร็วๆถึงเจอเสือ
นะคะอ๋อกูเองเหมือนเสือแล้วก็นักเรียน
ทำไมไม่เอาขึ้นใหม่เร็วๆใช่ไหมน่ากลัวนี่
แหละผู้หญิงแม่
อะไรคะอยู่ใช่ไหมดุเหมือนเสือหน้าครูหญิง
เนี่ยน่ารัก
ตั้งค่าค่ะคุยหยุดเลยนะคะ
คุณเป็นกระต่ายดิฉันไปเสืออ่ะคะ
นะคะเอ้าครูเอ๋แล้วคนไทยเนี่ยเปรียบเทียบ
ผู้หญิงกับอะไรอีกคะนอกจากสัตว์เนี่ยก็
เปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงกับพืชแอร์
กับพืชนะคะอ่าแต่ว่าเป็นดอกไม้
ดอกไม้อะไรกูเองมีรูปดอกไม้เนาะน้ำดอก
อะไรคะครูเอ๋เนี่ยดอกกุหลาบกุหลาบสีอะไร
สีเหลือง
ครูเอชอบกุหลาบสีเหลืองเหรอคะเอ๋ชอบ
กุหลาบสีเหลืองกุหลาบสีขาว
คนไทยเปรียบท่านผู้หญิงเหมือนดอกกุหลาบ
ไหมคะก็ดอกกุหลาบได้ดอกไม้หลายๆอย่างอ๋อ
เขาบอกว่าถ้ากุหลาบที่เป็นแบบนี้อันนี้
กุหลาบอะไรคะกุหลาบอยากยังไม่บานตูม
กุหลาบตูมอื้อ
อันนี้ก็เด็กผู้หญิงน้องอายุ 1 ปี
จนถึงประมาณ
12 ปีเนาะ
โน้ตชายผู้หญิงเด็กๆเหมือนดอกกุหลาบตูม
ดอกดอกกุหลาบดอกไม้ที่ตูมอยู่อ๋ออ๋อดอก
อะไรก็ได้ใช่มั้ยเพราะพี่เอ้ดอกกุหลาบ
โอเคดอก
ดอกมะลิโอเคราคา
ดอกออกไปไหนดอกบัวก็ได้แต่คือปุ่มตูมหลาก
โม้อันนี้ก็เป็นเด็กผู้หญิงเล็กๆค่ะแล้ว
ถ้าอายุ 13  14  15 เหมือนดอกไม้อะไรอ่ะ
คะ 13  14  15  16  17 แล้วจะเหมือนดอก
กุหลาบกำลัง
แก้มขอกำลังจำลังบ้านๆสีเขียวในกำลังเปิด
หล่ะนิดหน่อยโอเคไม่มีรูปค่ะหรอเห็นดอก
แต่ว่าถ้า 18  19  20
18  19  20  21  22  23  24 อ่ะโอเคค่ะ
เหมือนดอกไม้ยังไงอ่ะก็เหมือนดอกไม้ที่
กำลังบานออกมาขนาดนี้แล้วเอา
โอเคไหมกำลังสวยสบายแล้วทราย 25  26  27
อ่ะคะและก็เป็นดอกไม้อันนี้ค่ะ
บานซอย 25  26  27
สวยเลยใช่มั้ยสวยค่ะสวย 9  30 ได้นะคะค่ะ
แล้วถ้า
30  10  30 นใช่ไหม
30 ไปเรื่อยๆไม่เห็น
อายุ 30 ขึ้นไปก็เป็นดอกไม้บานเต็มบานจ้า
บ้าน 100% แล้วบานเต็มที่ค่ะผู้หญิงค่ะ
30 จะบานดอกไม้วานวันแล้วค่ะนี่อีกไหม
อ่า
อันนี้อะไรคะกุหลาบเหมือนกันเริ่ม 80 และ
อันนี้คุณยาย
บ้าแล้วก็มันจะรั่วนี้นะคะเราบอกว่า
เหี่ยวเหี่ยวเดี๋ยว
[เพลง]
เขาก็เปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงเหมือนกับดอกไม้
ดอกไม้ตูมดอกไม้แย้มดอกไม้เริ่มบาน
บานแล้วก็บานมากแล้วก็เหี่ยว
ไม่ว่างหรอกมันก็ร่วงหมดเลย
นักเรียนไม่ทันโหลดนะครับพี่เดี๋ยวผู้
หญิงฟังแล้ว
อันนี้คนไทย Keith คอนไทยขวยสวยนะทรายค่ะ
มีอีกไหมเขาก็บอกว่าบางทีเนี่ยผู้หญิงน่ะ
ก็ก็เป็นดอกไม้ดอกไม้ก็มีบางคนก็เป็นดอก
กุหลาบใช่ไหมค่ะ
ห่วยมากๆค่ะใส่แจกันนะคะค่ะบางคนก็เหมือน
ๆดอกมะลิโอ้ไม่เหมือนกันก็ไม่เหมือนกัน
อันนี้เล็กๆของ
หัวทำไมไม่ฆ่า
ผู้หญิงไทยมีชื่อมะลินี้ค่ะมีชื่อมะลิมี
ชื่อกุหลาบค่ะแล้วก็โอเคมีอันนี้ด้วยนะคะ
อันนี้มาลีไงคะเป็นพวงมาลัยมะลิออก
แล้วก็มีผู้หญิงไทยที่เหมือนดอกบัว
ยังไงคะผู้หญิงเหมือนดอกบัวเรียบร้อยอ๋อ
สวัสดีค่ะ
พูดเบาเบาๆหัวเราะเบาๆบ้านไม่ไปข้างนอก
on  / ซักผ้าเพราะครูเอ๋ไม่ใช่สอนทำ
อาหารซักผ้าแบบพูดมากก็ผัวไม่ได้จะซื้อ
ไหมผู้หญิงที่เหมือนดอกบัวต้องพูดนิด
หน่อยถ้า
ข้าข้าแต่งหน้าล่ะคะใจเย็นๆแล้วก็สวัสดี
สวัสดีค่ะตอนนี้นะคะน้อง
ค่ะคะเสื้อหญิงค่ะผู้หญิงนะคะ
แข็งแรงดีไหมคะแข็งแรงค่ะ
หลับอะไรคะเรื่องนอนแล้วค่อยคู๋เลี้ยง
ร้อยเรียบร้อยพูดเรียบร้อยเดินเรียบร้อย
นะคะอ่าก็เหมือนดอกบัว
ใช่เวลาที่เราเห็นผู้หญิงเรียบร้อยใจดีก็
คิดเหมือนดอกบัวแต่ๆผู้หญิงร้องโอ้โหถ้า
นักเรียนนักเรียนนะนักเรียน
นักเรียนเนี่ยเห็นใช่ไหมมีเพื่อน
เพื่อนแล้วก็ครูบอกผู้หญิงเรียบร้อย
เหมือนดอกบัวนักเรียนซื้อดอกบัวแล้วก็
ให้
ใครเพื่อนโอเคไหมโอเคก็เรียบร้อยไง
ไม่โอเค
ของไมก็นักเรียนบอกครูเอ๋บอกว่าผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเรียบร้อยพูดเบาๆชอบทำอาหารเหมือน
ดอกบัวนักเรียนก็คิดอยู่ดีอ่ะเฮ้ยดอกบัว
ไม่ตายเอาดอกบัวให้เพื่อนให้แฟนไม่ได้
ทำไมทำไมไม่ได้
จะเอาไว้ไหว้พระ
ผู้หญิงโกรธได้ไหมฉันไม่ใช่พระ
อันนี้พระนะคะนักเรียนค่ะ
เวลาไปวัดเหรอคะที่วัดเราก็มีดอกบัวแล้ว
ก็ไปไหว้พระณขณะไวร้านไม่ให้ผู้หญิงเก๋
งานนะเรียนบอกว่าว่าดอกบัวไม่ได้ดอกมะลิ
พวงมาลัยเหรอคะมาลัยมะลิเพราะว่าผู้หญิง
สวยพวงมาลัยคู๋บอกดอกมะลิเนี่ย
หอมก็มีดอกมะลิแล้วก็ให้เพื่อนผู้หญิงได้
ไหมให้แฟน
ไข้ได้แต่ผู้หญิงจะถ้า
ไม่ตกใจดีฉันไม่ใช่คุณแม่
โอเคดอกมะลิให้คุณแม่เหรอคะอันนี้คุณพ่อ
ใช่ไหมคะพ่อแม่
ลูก
มะลิสำหรับคุณแม่
ทั้งซื้อให้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็เถอะให้ว่า
ฉันแก่เหรอฉันเป็นแม่หรอ O คิดว่าดิฉัน
เป็นคุณแม่ไม่โอเคครูเอ๋มีค่าถ้า 500 ปี
ที่แล้วโอเคค่ะ
500 ปีที่แล้วมะลิให้ผู้หญิงโอเคดอกบัว
ให้ผู้หญิง
ตอนนี้ไม่ได้ดอกกุหลาบล่ะดอกกุหลาบให้ผู้
หญิงโอเคไหม
ดีมากดีมากนี่โอเคผู้หญิงนะคะ
ผู้หญิงเตะทีม
หือ
ดอกเอากับดอกลิลลี่ดอกคาร์เนชั่นให้ผู้
หญิงผู้หญิงยิ้มดอกบัว
คิดว่าผู้ชายไม่ชอบดิฉันก็มาไรอ๋อคิดว่า
ผู้ชายคิดว่ากูเองเป็นแม่แก่ๆ
ดูเอกคะสามีครูเอกเคยให้พวงมาลัยพูห์ a
ไหมเอ่อเลย
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้นะคะนักเรียนจริงๆแล้วผู้
หญิงถามว่ามึงอยากรู้
Hi ค่ะวันวาเลนไทน์มี 1 ครั้งสามีคู๋
ซื้อพวงมาลัยแต่ตรงนี้เป็นดอกกุหลาบ
[เพลง]
ดอกกุหลาบ
ปี้วาเลนไทน์
ไม่ใช่พระไม่ใช่แม่
ๆมั้ยไม่ใช่คนไทยก็เลยไม่เข้าใจคิดโอ้สวย
ก็ซื้อให้หนัง x  x  x  n  n ไม่เอานะคะ
นักเรียนเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงใจสร้อยไม่เอา
อ่ะแล้วกลับไปค่ะเขามีมีเปรียบเทียบผู้
หญิงกับดอกไม้แล้วใช่ไหมคะต้นไม้ดอกมี
เปรียบเทียบกับของด้วยคู่หญิงอุ้ยเปรียบ
เทียบกับอะไรคะผู้หญิงกับอัญมณีไปไหน
อัญมณีนี่ที่ไหนๆโห
Ed  Caps เห็ด H ผู้หญิงเหมือนเพชรเหรอ
คะ
ผู้หญิงบางคนเหมือนเพชร
บางคนเหมือนแบบนี้ค่ะอันนี้อะไรคะอันนี้
ก็จะมีอะไรนะมีสีเขียวมรกต
ค่ะมีเพชรมีไข่มุกก็สีเหลืองแล้วคะอันนี้
เป็นบุษราคัม
ดูหนังสีชมพู
ทับทิมสีแดงๆส้มๆอันนี้อันนี้มาทำไมเนี่ย
อันนี้ยังไงประกาลังค่ะประการัง
เพชรตาแมวแล้วก็ครูเอ๋นั้นเพศตาแมวค่ะค่ะ
แล้วสีน้ำเงินฟ้าๆนะคะไข่ลินนะคะอันสุด
ท้ายเอ่อ
เพทายมันค่ะ
ไม่เหมือนกันหรอคะไม่เหมือนเพชรไม่เหมือน
ไม่เหมือนอาทั้งหมดตรงนี้เป็นพลอยส่วนอัน
นี้เป็นเพชรนะคะผู้หญิงไทยมีชื่อมรกตนี่
ค่ะชื่อบุษราคัมมีค่ะอื้อทับทิมมีค่ะคือ
ไข่มุกมีค่ะอื้อไพลินมีค่ะหน้าอันนี้นะมี
ก็เปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงพี่เพชรเป็นพลอย
สวย
ชายแล้วก็แข็งแรงไหมเออถ้ารักมากๆก็คิด
ว่าเหมือนเพชรขอก็ต้องมีหวงมากๆ
ๆแพงมากๆตายต้องดูดีๆๆนะคะเอามีอีกมีอีก
ผู้หญิงแล้วเปรียบผู้หญิงเหมือนอะไรอีกคะ
ครูเอ๋
อาหาร
ทำไมอ่ะอ้าวมีงานอะไรอ่ะ
อันนี้อาหารไทยค่ะ
อาหารไทยเขาบอกว่าผู้หญิงที่อุ้ยผู้
สวยๆเหมือนเค้กหรอทำไมคุยเอานี่มา
สวยๆมันเค้กอ่ะโอ้นี่ออกเหมือนเหมือนของ
หวานมันเค้กไปเห้ยผู้หญิงบางคนเหมือนของ
หวานมันเค้กค่ะสวยๆน่ารักๆเห็นไหมสวยก็ดู
หวานหวานๆสวยมีผลไม้ดีครีม
ๆแต่ว่าบางคนก็เหมือนลาภอันนี้เพจนะกูเอ๋
ที่บ้านอร่อยๆอร่อยบางคนก็เขาก็บอกว่า
เน็ต
[เพลง]
อะที่บ้านคนไทยเนี่ยชอบกินน้ำพริกค่ะ
คุยมีรูปน้ำพริกเยอะเลยโจ๊กอันนี้หญิงก็
เปิดน้ำพริกเหรอคะพี่เอ๋ใช่ๆ
อันเนี้ยน้ำพริกแล้วก็อ่ะอัดนะคะ
ค่ะอ่ะมีแตงกวามะเขือ
ถั่วอะไรอีกครั้งอันนี้เป็นอะไรอ่ะอันนี้
ชะอมค่ะมีผักเยอะๆนะคะ
เวลาคนไทยน่ะผู้หญิงบ้านครูหญิงน่ะเวลา
คุณหญิงเด็กๆที่บ้านครูหญิงมีไหมคะเนี่ย
น้ำพริกน่ะมีซ่ามีน้ำพริกมีปลาไหมคะมีค่ะ
ข้าวถ่ายเราก็ค่ะมีผลักมีเกือบทุกวันไหม
ทุกวันน้ำพริกเนี่ยเปิดดูอ่ะน้ำพริกพรุ่ง
นี้เปิดดูน้ำพริกมีทุกวันค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้
หญิงเบื่อไหม
ไม่อยากกินน้ำพริกแม่ไม่เอาน้ำพริกอ้ะ
เมื่อวานก็น้ำพริกน้ำพริกทุกวันทุกวันไม่
กินเห็นเค้กอยากกินไหมล่ะแต่กูอยากกินที่
บ้านไม่มีอยู่บ้านไม่มี
สวยจังเลย
หือนะคะให้เขาก็เปรียบเทียบว่าผู้หญิง
แต่งงานแล้วอยู่ที่ค่ะก็เหมือนน้ำพริกต่อ
เบื่อแล้วหรอคู๋กินทุกวัน
เห็นทุกวันทุกวันให้
เป็นโจ๊กคนไทยแล้วเบื่อนิดหน่อยอ่าและก็
อยากจะไปอู้เค้กสวยใช่ไหมคะ
เค้กกินทุกวันได้ไหมไม่ได้แล้วไม่อร่อย
กินแล้วเป็นยังไงคะไม่สบายไม่สบายเอาแล้ว
แต่ถ้าชีบ้าน 1 วันไม่มีน้ำพริกล่ะไม่มี
น้ำพริกแต่ขอบอกเบื่อๆน้ำพริกไม่มีน้ำ
พริกกินข้าวไม่อร่อยชายก็แม่น้ำพริกที่
ไหนไม่ทำแล้วเอาอยากกินน้ำพริกไปซื้อเค้ก
กินไม่คิดหรอหากินเค้กไม่ไหวแล้วท้องไม่
โอเคคิดถึงน้ำพริกใช่มั้ยน้องพริกอร่อยนะ
คะก็มีเยอะ
จบบางคนเปรียบเทียบใช่ไหมครับคุณแม่
เหมือนน้ำพริก
เบื่อแต่อร่อยตายเบื่อแต่ไม่มีน้ำพริกน้ำ
พริกที่ไหนน้ำพริกน้ำพริกจะคิดถึงนะเพลง
ใจค่ะคือของภรรยานะคะเป็นภรรยาภรรยา
เหมือนน้ำพริกต้องต้องมีทุกวันต้องเห็น
หน้าทุกวันนะคะเอาเปรียบและสุดท้าย
เปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงเหมือนอะไรอีกผู้หญิง
เหมือนพระจันทร์หนูกลมกลมๆเหรอคะ
0 สวยของ
คนเดียวนักเรียนจะโกรธหรอกน่าฉันอันนี้นะ
ผู้หญิงเฮ้ยหน้ากูหญิงไงนักเรียนตัวเอง
วาดให้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเหมือนพระจันทร์เลย
ผู้หญิงเหมือนไหมผู้หญิงเหมือนพระจันทร์
นะสวยไม่ใช่กลม
หัวนิตาเหรอถ้าครูเอง
ก็มีฟันใหญ่ๆนะงั้น 2  4
หากผู้หญิงเหมือนพระจันทร์ยังไงอ่ะ
และขอคนไทยบอกผู้หญิงเหมือนพระจันทร์
สวยเหมือนพระจันทร์
แล้วพระอาทิตย์หรอคะ
พระอาทิตย์แล้วนะคะคุณพระอาทิตย์
[เพลง]
พระอาทิตย์เป็นผู้ชาย
อ้าวทำไมอ่ะร้อนหรอ
ไม่รู้พระอาทิตย์หรือผู้ชายพระจันทร์ผู้
หญิงโหคนไทยคิดใช่ไหมคุยคนไทยเปรียบเทียบ
เปรียบเทียบผู้หญิงเป็นพระจานผู้ชายเป็น
พระอาทิตย์ผู้หญิงสวยเหมือนพระจันทร์เวลา
ดูแล้วสบายๆอ๋อผู้ชายแบบใกล้ชิดชอบร้อน
แข็งแรงก็ได้เนาะ
นะคะค่ะมีคู๋ลืมบอกผู้หญิงอะไรจะบอกหรือ
ยังบอกว่าผู้หญิงเป็นดอกไม้ใช่ไหมเอาไว้
ค่ะผู้ชายเป็นพึ่งหรอ
อ๋อ
ชายเป็นพึ่งตอนนี้ซึ่งชอบดอกไม้อะไรคู่
กันแต่อันนี้แมลงภู่ค่ะอ๋อกูชายเป็นแมลง
ผู้หญิงเป็นดอกไม้ค่ะ
ว่าอะไรนะผู้ชายเป็น
เป็นพระจันทร์ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเป็นพระ
จันทร์ผู้ชายเป็นพระอาทิตย์ค่ะ
นะคะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักแล้วเนาะว่า
เรา
เปรียบเทียบนะคะเปรียบป่าเปรียบเทียบคน
กับต้นไม้
สาบคนกับมีสิ่งของค่ะและเปรียบเทียบดีนะ
ไม่ใช่ไม่ดีนะดีๆสมัยสวยเหมือนอะไรสวย
เหมือนดอกไม้ใช่ไหมเรียบร้อยเหมือนอะไร
ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็
สำคัญใช่ว่าอันนี้ 2 คันไม่มีไม่ได้น้ำ
พริกไม่มีไม่อร่อยกินข้าวไม่อร่อยตายค่ะ
อ่ะทั้งหมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะ Hi ค่ะก็ไป
กินก๋วยจั๊บไปกินน้ำพริกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่
ต้องไม่
มีค่ะไปหาก่อนตัว a ญาติกินนมริกว่าใคร
ผู้หญิงกับกูเองต้องไปหาน้ำพริกแล้วค่ะ
นักเรียนเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้า
นะคะสวัสดีสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายน